we need measured and competent leaders
who we can trust right okay and here's
where I have to hit Trump on something
because Trump sent out a couple posts on
Truth social and it's like he could
comment on the election and say hey this
is what went wrong this is what went
right these are the ideas we stand for
this is what they stand for people
didn't come around there I would have
like the way I would have liked but
instead he's going back to some of his
old stuff and I just don't think this is
the stuff we need anymore here's a post
on truth from Trump he wrote young kin
now he's talking about Glenn young young
kin now that's an interesting take
sounds Chinese doesn't it in Virginia
couldn't have won without me Trump wrote
on Truth social the social media
platform he helped found I endorsed him
did a very big Trump rally for him
telephonically got Maga to vote for him
or he couldn't have come close to
winning but he knows that and admits it
besides having a hard time with the Dems
in Virginia but he'll get it done look I
don't know what is he trying to to imply
that somehow he's Chinese or something
young can like we just don't need this
no one in their right mind Donald Trump
anyone that is an Associated Donald
Trump again I voted for you I like you
we don't need these games anymore if
you're if you think that Glenn yunkin is
the enemy
if you think that Ron DeSantis is the
enemy then you gotta find the mirror
right like you got to look at yourself
and go what am I really trying to do
here am I trying to make this all about
me or am I trying to find the best
possible people to put in these jobs to
to lead to a country that is something
like the country I want to live in Glenn
young basically is doing a great job in
Virginia and and the proof is in the
pudding Ron DeSantis is absolutely
crushing it in Florida and the people
see it so I don't think these tricks are
going to work Glenn youngin actually had
a nice response to to the Trump post
what's your reaction first of all I
didn't see it um
I have to be honest I've been busy all
morning
um listen I I you you all know me I do I
do not uh call people names I I really
work hard to bring people together and
that's what we're working on well that's
what I'm saying and and I just that's
not the way I roll and not the way I
behave and and I think again this is a
moment for us to come together
yeah that's kind of right like we can
lick our chops we can or lick our wounds
rather we can lick our wounds and go all
right well what's going on here what do
we have to do to be better and is it
better to throw out these bombs and
young Kim and what Ron de sanctimonious
like this stuff or to lay out better
policies like what actually do people
want I think we're the mature group I
think we're the side that actually wants
Clarity and competency